bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat après 9h30 des
discussions autour de l'article 1 du
projet loi mariage pour tous et bien le
sénat s'apprête ce soir à la reprise de
la séance vous entendez la sonnerie qui
retentit à voter sur cet article
symbolique fondateur du texte puisque
c'est celui qui institue le mariage pour
tous les couples donc scrutin public
dans quelques instants en séance avant
d'avoir jean pierre raffarin notre micro
ont rejoint quelques secondes delphine
girard qui se trouve dans la tribune de
presse dans l'hémicycle du sénat
oui bonsoir perrine bonsoir à tous alors
vous l'avez dit enfin on va le suspense
va se terminer puisque à la reprise de
la séance les sénateurs vont enfin se
prononcer sur cet article premier qui je
vous le rappelle est le coeur de ce
projet de loi puisqu'il modifie le code
civil en ouvrant le mariage et
l'adoption aux couples de même sexe
alors la séance a été suspendue pendant
deux heures car l'ump a demandé pour la
deuxième fois depuis le début de
l'examen de ce projet de loi
la vérification du quorum et le quorum
n'étant pas atteint et bien il a fallu
suspendre la séance avant de voter voilà
péri dans tous les cas et bien dès qu'on
entend le résultat on revient dans cette
séance mais je crois que vous êtes à
présent avec un premier invité
bonsoir jean pierre raffarin qui est
effectivement avec nous en direct donc
le sénat s'apprête à voter sur cet
article
un dut du projet de loi vous êtes
confiant sur le vote
combien coûte et je pense que les
socialistes organisent toujours des
votes public pour que naturellement
leurs insuffisances numérique soit
compensée par cette procédure au fond ce
qui est important c'est que on voit bien
que c'est un débat gâcher quoi parce
qu'on n'aurait plus discutés sur les
couples on voit bien qu'il peut y avoir
des proximités sur l'adoption il faut
repenser un certain nombre de choses on
était bien d'accord mais au fond les
gens ne s'écoute pas ici et donc est la
droite parle mais la gauche n'écoute pas
vraiment et au total finalement c'est
une forme d'incompréhension il n'y a pas
vraiment débat koala la gauche a décidé
de toute façon de faire bloc sans
cligner liberté de vote et donc elles se
préparent à voter donc nous nous faisons
ce que nous pouvons pour exprimer nos
idées et alerter sur sept divisions
inutiles des français mais la gauche
sans tête et continue à avancer dans
cette direction de division dommage
c'est de bonne guerre non jean pierre
raffarin chacun est dans son rôle la
droite vous fait durer les débats 9h30
quand même de discussion autour de cet
article premier c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal mais le fond de la faire c'est que
est ce qu on avait besoin de ce débat là
on voit bien que la france aujourd'hui
est en crise sociale il ya une crise
morale en plus rajouté cette fracture
sociétale
c'est absurde et la grogne la gronde
gagne le pays et tout ça on voit qu'une
détention qui était inutile dans la
crise dans laquelle nous sommes il faut
que le gouvernement se ressent sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire l'emploi
et s'il retirait ce texte ça pèserait
beaucoup la situation dans le pays
françois rebsamen vous a demandé tout à
l'heure a enfin demandé à ses troupes
pardon dans l'hémicycle du sénat ne pas
céder à la provocation des sénateurs ump
est ce que vous avez l'impression d'être
provocateur lors de ce débat pas du tout
mais françois rebsamen a appelé ces
sénateurs au calme c'est vrai qu'ils
avaient chahuté une sénatrice de manière
assez incorrect et au fond il faut
apprendre à les séparer les autres mais
vous même sur les bandes à droite vous
avez aussi pas mal chahuté les orateurs
de la gauche hausse et d'une manière
générale nous écoutons d'ailleurs la
gauche n'a pas été très éloquente sur
ces sujets elle est assez discrète et au
fond elle attend le résultat tous
groupés derrière son obligation de vote
il n'y a pas ce débat de conscience
qu'on aurait aimé avoir avec des gens de
gauche on entend la sonnerie du scrutin
public et entendit j'imagine que vous
avez envie d'aller voter dans
l'hémicycle donc je vous libère
jean-pierre enfin merci d'avoir été en
direct à notre micro donc pour ce
scrutin public autour de l'article 1 du
projet de loi mariage pour tous qui
débute en ce moment dans l'hémicycle
article je le répète encore une fois
c'est l'article évidemment fondateur
symbolique de ce texte us et celui qui
institue le mariage pour tous les
couples donc après 9 heures et demie de
débat ici au sénat et bien les sénateurs
votent enfin par un scrutin public à la
tribune sur cet article
a priori il n'y a pas vraiment de
suspens l'article 1 ne devrait pas être
ne devrait pas être rejeté par le sénat
même si la majorité de gauche ici était
assez courte je vous rappelle seulement
six voix d' avance de la gauche sur la
droite
ici au sénat mais bon il ne devrait pas
y avoir de suspense ce soir dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
pour le vote autour de cet article 1er
du projet de loi mariage pour tous alors
pour voir un petit peu ce qui se passe
dans l'hémicycle du sénat
eh bien on va à nouveau rejoindre
delphine girard qui se trouve dans la
tribune de presse
oui perrine mais le vote de cet article
le premier a lieu par scrutin public
vous le savez c'est une procédure qui
permet à un sénateur de 100 groupes de
voter par délégation pour les autres
scrutins
il ya eu de nombreux scrutins publics
cet après midi mais toujours à la
demande des socialistes
et bien ce soir pour la reprise de cette
séance sur l'article 1er c'est un
scrutin public qui a été demandée mais
non pas par les socialistes mais pour le
groupe ump alors j'entends le président
du sénat jean-pierre bel derrière moi
qui vient de clore le scrutin le
dépouillement va donc avoir lieu dans un
instant et on va pouvoir dévoiler les
résultats
vous l'avez dit perrine a priori n'y a
pas beaucoup de suspense sur cet article
en tous les cas les débats auront été
long mais c'est l'essentiel de ce texte
souvent les orateurs qui ont pris la
parole les sénateurs ump lorsqu'ils se
sont exprimés sur cette article premier
à différentes reprises ils ont multiplié
les prises de parole et bien expliqué
que en votant en rejetant cet article le
premier s'était déjà s'il s'exprime
comme s'il s'exprimait pardon sur
l'ensemble de ce projet de loi c'est
vrai que cet article premier et on l'a
dit et redit c'est le coeur de ce projet
de loi puisqu'il modifie le code civil
tel qu'il a été défini en 1804 il ouvre
le mariage et l'adoption aux couples de
même sexe alors cette nuit les sénateurs
vont poursuivre le débat c'est ce qui a
été décidé ce soir c'est vrai qu'ils ont
pris vient pas mal de retard 1 9h30 vous
l'avais dit avant de se prononcer sur
cet article 1er et au final il y a
toujours quasiment 260 amendements à
examiner avant le vote final
alors comme on l'a vu la droite
sénatoriale jouer l'obstruction et
celles à ralentir les débats
donc on va pouvoir retourner dans
l'hémicycle pour suivre en direct le
résultat de ce scrutin qui vont delphine
voilà jean pierre bel le président du
sénat qui préside cette séance
importante ce soir autour du projet de
loi mariage pour tous et bien et à la
tribune on est en train de dépouiller le
scrutin public et dans quelques instants
et bien jean pierre bel le président du
sénat va annoncer ce résultat on le
répète pas de suspense
youri l'article devrait être adoptée par
le sénat mais on attend de voir quand
même quel est l'écart de voix sur cet
article
un article qui institue dans le cadre de
ce projet doit bien le mariage pour tous
les couples et ça va être intéressant de
voir quel est l'écart de voix entre la
gauche et la droite ce sera sans doute
un indicateur peut-être pour le vote
ensuite sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
vote qui n'interviendra pas avant la fin
de la semaine
on parle maintenant d'un vote sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi sans doute
dans la journée voire dans la soirée de
vendredi si ce n'est dans la journée de
samedi
effectivement les débats ici sur ce
projet de loi ont pris pas mal de retard
les sénateurs de l'opposition ont
multiplié les interventions les prises
de parole les explications de vote sur
chaque amendement pour essayer de faire
un petit peu durer le débat autour de
cet article 1er du projet loi mariage
pour tous et ils ont plutôt réussi leurs
affaires puisque on a pris beaucoup de
retard dans l'examen de ce projet de loi
voilà c'est le jeu on va dire du
parlement la gauche est assez
silencieuse elle laisse la droite faire
son travail d'opposant elle attend un
peu que leur âge passent d'ailleurs
françois rebsamen le chef de file des
sénateurs socialistes a dit tout à
l'heure à ces sénateurs ne cédez pas à
la provocation de la droite on écoute le
résultat du vote sur cet article et
premier chien projet de loi nombre de
votants 342 nombre de suffrages exprimés
336 majorité absolue
169 pour l'adoption 179 contre 157 le
sénat a adopté l'article premier du
projet de loi
monsieur monsieur le président de la
commission des lois vous avez demandé la
parole je vous remercie monsieur le
président cette article 1er bien sur
l'article principal essentiel de ce
projet de loi il me semble qu'après les
longs débats que nous avons eus très
riche il est utile peut être de
rationaliser quelque peu nos discussions
c'est pourquoi monsieur le président en
vertu de l'article 44 alinéa 6 du
règlement
je vous propose que nous traitions en
priorité de la totalité des articles
issus de l'assemblée nationale de
manière à examiner ensuite l'ensemble
des articles additionnels bien merci
monsieur le président donc je rappelle
que lorsque la réserve est demandé par
la commission saisie au fort elle est de
droit si le gouvernement ne s'y oppose
pas quel est l'avis du gouvernement
madame le ministre
aucune opposition de la part du vrm
ancien président
merci donc la réserve tous les articles
additionnels à la fin du projet de loi
et ordonnée nous passons donc à l'examen
de l'article 1er bis un sur cet article
j'ai eu deux demandes de parole de
monsieur philippe bas oui monsieur le
président je dois dire que cet article
me surprend et je n'en comprends pas
bien le sens il est dit dans ce projet
d'article 34 1 du code civil que les
actes de l'état civil sont établis par
les officiers de l'état civil jusqu'ici
naturellement aucune divergence cela va
de soi et ça ne nous change pas par
rapport au droit existant mais il et
d'ajouter ces derniers exercent leurs
fonctions sous le contrôle et la
surveillance du procureur de la
république
alors je m'interroge je me demande ce
que sera le contenu de ce contrôle de
cette surveillance et les conséquences
qu'il faudra en tirer
faut-il voir dans cet article la
traduction concrète des engagements pris
par le président de la république au
congrès de l'association des maires de
france
quand il a imaginé qu'une une clause de
conscience pourrait permettre un maire
de ne pas célébrer un mariage j'avais
cru comprendre pourtant que après avoir
reçu toutes affaires cessantes le
lendemain matin au palais de l'elysée
des représentants de groupes de pression
en faveur du mariage des personnes de
même sexe le président de la république
s'était rétracté alors naturellement la
question se pose de savoir ce que fera
le procureur de la république lorsqu'un
maire ne souhaitera pas un procès d un
mariage vous en dit
ou bien trop peu parce que nous ne
savons pas les conséquences qui seront
tirés de ces dispositions le contenu de
ce contrôle le contenu de cette
surveillance les pouvoirs qui s'y
rattachent ou ou pas assez d'une
certaine façon et par conséquent il me
semble qu'ils seraient de notre part
très imprudent de souscrire à une
disposition aussi flou sous réserve
toutefois que le gouvernement veuille
bien l'explicité merci monsieur bah je
n'ai plus de demandes de parole sur un
article
j'appelle l'amendement 7 rectifié bis
qui sera présent vous l'avez entendu si
vous soulevez la séance en direct
l'article 1er a donc été adopté par le
sénat par 179 voix contre 157
applaudissements nourris de la majorité
sénatoriale hué sur les bancs de la
droite d'autant que jean bien sûr le
président socialiste de la commission
des lois a pris la parole pour demander
à ce que les débats les discussions
soient le plus rationnel il a donc
appelé en priorité bien les articles
issus de l'assemblée nationale et les
articles additionnels ce qui ont été
donc modifié par le sénat vont être
discutés plus tard dans ce débat alors
la séance se poursuit on a pu l'entendre
avec les prises de parole sur les
articles donc qui suivent l'article 1er
et on va rentrer dans un sujet très
important pour les sénateurs puisqu'il
s'agit et bien des modalités de
l'application de ce mariage pour tous et
vous le savez certains sénateurs ont
déjà fait valoir qu'il ferait bien ce
comment dirait bien qu'il mettra en
application leur clause de conscience
s'ils avaient à se prononcer à célébrer
eux mêmes des mariage entre couples de
même sexe vous proposons tout de suite
de retourner en séance pour écouter à
les explications sur ce thème cet
article est ainsi vote monsieur g là je
vais donc demander l'avis de monsieur le
rapporteur sur l'article 16 rectifié bis
le monde la commission est défavorable à
cet amendement
en effet il nous semble que cet
amendement
cet article l'amendement supprime un
article qui a le mérite d'établir
clairement la règle selon laquelle les
officiers d'état civil exercent leurs
fonctions sous le contrôle et la
surveillance du procureur de la
république sur le contrôle expérience
d'ailleurs nous accepterons tout à
l'heure un amendement de monsieur girard
qui allège cette notion cette mention
est bienvenu dans le code civil n
existait pas aujourd'hui elle existe
c'est un fait
tous les maires qui sont ici le savent
c'est le procureur a répliqué la tutelle
soldats et un civil tous les ans dont
dix en voyant le double des registres et
bien là il est dit que c'est lui qui
doit contrôler la tenue des zincs état
civil et des registres
merci monsieur le rapporteur je vais
demander l'avis du gouvernement madame
madame la garde des sceaux madame la
présidente monsieur le doyen gélard un
avis défavorable du gouvernement pour la
suppression de cet article je vous
rappel de toutes façons ce que vous
savez parfaitement que le l'état civil
et placé sous la responsabilité du
service public judiciaire etc au
quotidien les officiers d'état civil
sont appelés à solliciter le parquet
pour lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à une
difficulté dans la rédaction d'un acte
qui peut être un acte de naissance qui
peut n'avoir rien à voir avec le mariage
directement
donc c'est un rappel de cela pour le
reste les dispositions je vous
rappellerai pas non plus la loi de 2005
sur la filiation et qui a établi l'unité
livret de famille et la chancellerie
travaille d'ailleurs avec les éditeurs
de logiciels puisque nous avons un
livret de famille unique qui s'adapte
simplement il n'y a donc aucune raison
dans les arguments que vous allez
présenter d'accepter la suppression de
cet article avis défavorable merci
madame la ministre je vais mettre aux
voix
la maman 7 rectifié bis oui changer la
vie inscrits
le cese rectifié bis veille active des
explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je suis saisi d'une
demande d'explication de scrutin public
sur l'article sur l'amendement 16
rectifié bis
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable que l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront secrétaire un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre un
bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir métro un bulletin rouge de ce
que le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà encore un scrutin public dans la
cadre de ce projet de loi mariage pour
tous il faut dire que ces scrutins
publics se multiplient depuis deux jours
ici au sénat alors la droite accuse la
gauche de ne pas être assez de
nombreuses à se mobiliser dans
l'hémicycle et donc de demander pour
chaque vote sur un amendement aussi un
article un scrutin public est toujours
est il que bon c'est ce que t'en vas pas
aller assez vite je vous rappelle que il
y à quelques minutes quelques instants
et bien le sénat vient d'adopter par 179
voix pour 157 contre l'article premier
de ce projet de loi article qui institue
qui ouvre le mariage aux aux homosexuels
pardon donc article évidemment fondateur
au coeur de ce projet de loi et qui a il
ya une majorité finalement assez
confortable pour adopter cet article
premier au sénat
en tout cas plus confortable que n'est
que ne l'est la réelle majorité de la
gauche est ici au sénat seulement six
petites voix d'avancé je vous le
rappelle pour la gauche ici au sénat sur
la droite donc la 79 pour l'article
premier contre 157 contre majorité plus
confortable que prévu on verra ce qu'il
en sera à la fin de la semaine
quant au vote sur l'ensemble du projet
de loi la majorité là sera certainement
un petit peu plus resserrée parce qu'il
y a des sénateurs qui sont pour
l'ouverture du mariage homosexuel mais
qui sont contre en revanche l'adoption
plénière par exemple pour les enfants
dans le cadre de couples homosexuels
bref certains sénateurs ne sont pas
d'accord sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
et pourrait voter contre alors qu'ils
ont voté pour l'article premier chien
voilà on va reprendre le chemin de
l'hémicycle
puisque le scrutin est clos le
dépouillement est en cours et on va
connaître dans quelques instants
delphine girard ou qui est en tribune de
presse est bien le résultat du vote sur
cet amendement
oui vous l'avez dit un perrine le
dépouillement est en cours et on risque
d'avoir ce soir encore de nombreux
scrutins publics qui ralentissent les
débats alors vous l'avez dit et bien cet
après midi c'est la droite qui a accusé
la gauche de ne pas être assez
nombreuses pour voter ce soir c'est
peut-être l'un vers s'il ya eu déjà deux
fois des demandes de scrutins publics à
la demande du groupe ump
en tous les cas on ne devrait pas tarder
à rentrer je vous le disais dans un
sujet qui tient à coeur au sénateur cdh
et sénateurs qui sont souvent mères
puisque ils ont commencé par rappeler
que lors de l'association du congrès le
congrès de l'association des maires de
france
françois hollande avait expliqué aux
élus et aux mères et bien que leurs
adjoints ne seraient pas obligées de
célébrer des mariages si elles leur
conscience s'y opposer de nombreux
amendements sont proposés ce soir
il envisage le cas où aucun officier
d'état civil est bien de quelques
communes en fait n'accepte de célébrer
le mariage et donc des amendements
proposent des solutions pour les couples
concernés
on va effectivement retourner dans
l'hémicycle pour suivre en direct le
dépouillement de ce premier de ce
premier scrutin public bonne science et
a tout de suite
merci delphine on vous retrouve un peu
plus tard lors de cette séance pour
d'autres commentaires en direct de la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat on attend le résultat du vote sur
cet amendement de patrice gélard qui
était soutenue par la commission des
lois du sénat c'est vrai que les
discussions là dans l'est dans l'eure où
les deux heures qui suivaient bien vont
porter autour de cette clause de
conscience des maires il y avait un
papier dans le figaro aujourd'hui qui
évoqué le chiffre de quelques 2000
communes en france qui serait totalement
opposé à la célébration de mariages
homosexuels homosexuels et donc
effectivement il va falloir trouver des
parades à des cas de figure pour voir un
petit peu si on peut ou non obliger les
maires les officiers d'état civil à
célébrer ces mariages ou s'il peut y
avoir des mesures pour contourner ces
décisions voilà bariza khiari qui est
vice-présidente socialiste du sénat va
donc dans quelques instants annoncer le
résultat de ce scrutin public autour de
cet amendement 2 patrice gélard et puis
après la discussion va reprendre son
cours va reprendre le fil dans
l'hémicycle du sénat sur ce texte sur ce
projet de mariage pour tous voilà le
résultat
ibis à l'article 1er bis du projet de
loi
nombre de votants 324 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 321 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 161 pour
l'adoption 146 contre
75 le sénat n'a pas adopté
je suis saisi de deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur gélard vous présenter les deux
amendements
oui madame la présidente même la
présidente par le garde des sceaux m
lamy nice ces amendements sur des
amendements de repli après le l'échec de
l'amendement précédent dans l'amendement
84 rectifié bis il suffit de supprimer
la seconde phrase dans l'alinéa 2
c'est-à-dire cette seconde phrase est la
suivante ces derniers exercent leurs
fonctions sous le contrôle et la
surveillance du procureur de la
république
et puis le l'amendement suivant le 10ème
rectifié bis consiste à supprimer n'ont
pas le contrôle du procureur de la
république mais la surveillance du prion
du rockeur de la république
si monsieur g là je vais demander l'avis
du rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
bien il ne vous échappera pas que sur
l'amendement 84 rectifié bis nous sommes
défavorable puisque monsieur l'a dit
lui-même tel amendement de repli donc de
santé favorable par contre la commission
était favorable à l'amendement 17
rectifier pis qu'ils gardent contrôle
savait que contrôle et surveillance sa
part est redondant donc nous sommes
favorables à ce deuxième amendement
sauf si monsieur l'art le retire mais
nous sommes favorables non pardon
favorable pour le botté pardon merci
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre sur ces
deux amendements concernant la
surveillance le
gouvernement va émettre un avis de
sagesse et s'en remettre dans que vote
des sénatrices et sénateurs le contrôle
et la surveillance n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose mais je ne suis pas choqué
de la suppression de du terme
surveillance le deuxième voilà vingt
quatre rectifié bis madame mini-cd
favorable oui merci bien
je vais mettre aux voix à une
explication de vote monsieur longuet
madame la présidente madame la garde des
sceaux michèle collègues
oui je m'exprimerai brièvement sans
abuser de mon temps de parole sur ces
deux amendements présentés par mon
excellent collègue sur le doyen gélard
est donc l'expression l'esprit même a
été présentée précédemment
notre intervention a pour objet de
rappeler aux trente six mille maires de
france aux adjoints qui sont officiers
d'état civil de leur rappeler à qui ils
doivent à qui ils devront demain
l'obligation de procéder à ces mariages
il y avait des doutes président de la
république avait ouvert un doute dans
son expression publique lors du congrès
des maires
beaucoup d'entre nous étions présents
nous avions le sentiment que le
président de la république c'est dans ta
une sorte de de remords tardifs
envisageait que l'on puisse ne pas être
adhéré spontanément à l'idée d'un
mariage faisant fi de l'altérité
il est revenu là lui arrive il est
revenu sur 7
prise de conscience sur sept ce doute
sur cette réserve sur cette restriction
et il décide à travers le projet
gouvernemental repris par la commission
des lois par notre commission des lois
d'imposer aux élus qui ont été élus bien
avant cette loi qui ont été lues sans la
connaître qui ont été élus dans un
esprit de tradition concernant
l'altérité dans le mariage d'avoir
l'obligation absolue sous le contrôle
mais peut-être grâce à la sagesse du
sénat sans la surveillance du ministère
public de procéder à ces mariages
auront-ils suffisamment de conviction
auront-ils suffisamment de persuasion
intime pour faire partager à
l'assistance est d'abord au futur couple
toute la légitimité de cette
construction
je ne le sais pas en tous les cas même
s'il doute même s'ils ne sont pas
certains de pouvoir communiquer alors
aux candidats aux impétrants l'intimé
conviction de la validité de cette union
et de sa construction dans le temps il
sera obligé de le faire bien nous avons
tenu à travers ces deux amendements a
rappelé le volte face de monsieur le
président la république et à permettre à
notre assemblée par des scrutins publics
de dissiper toute ambiguïté sur la
responsabilité qui pèsera parmi notre
haute assemblée sur ceux d'entre nous
qui sont favorables à l'idée de faire fi
de toute réserve de conviction les
journalistes ont des réserves de
conviction par les élus locaux
ils n'auront pas ils n'auront pas grâce
à ceux qui voteront qui refuseront ces
amendements
eh bien nous tenions nous à le faire
savoir pour que nul n'en ignore
dans les 36000 communes de france merci
messieurs longuet je suis donc c'est
monsieur sur monsieur monsieur le
président
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues je tiens juste à dire un mot
monsieur longuet a employé un argument
en disant ces maires ont été élus alors
que la présente loi n'aura pas été votée
mais cet argument m'étonne beaucoup à
tout instant nous de vons appliquer la
loi de la république et le fait même que
l'on puisse utiliser cet argument
m'étonne beaucoup
merci monsieur le président j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe ump sur l'amendement 86
rectifié bis de monsieur gélard je vous
rappelle que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable l'avis du gouvernement est
défavorable
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre un
bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est ouvert nous pardon pardon
voilà pendant ce nouveau scrutin un
public à la tribune et bien je vous
propose de revoir tout à l'heure
l'annnonce du résultat sur la non du
résultat du vote sur l'article premier
du projet loi mariage pour tous article
premier qui ouvre le mariage aux couples
homosexuels vous propose de réécouter ce
vote on va ré écouter cette séquence
avec une majorité plus confortable que
prévu on l'écoutait annonce des
résultats du scrutin numéro 148 sur
l'article premier du projet de loi
nombre de votants 342 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
336 majorité absolue 169 pour l'adoption
179 contre 157 le sénat a adopté
l'article premier du projet de loi
voilà c'était il ya à peine un petit
quart d'heure ici au sénat l'adoption de
cet article 1er du projet de loi
mariage pour tous aucune majorité assez
confortable pour adopter cet article 1er
delphine girard vous êtes dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle vous
avais le détail de ce vote racontez nous
un petit peu qui a voté pour qui a voté
contre
oui perrine effectivement alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir et bien le
vote des sénateurs ump
alors les sénateurs ump qui ont voté
pour sans surprise son christian cointat
jacqueline farreyrol de fabienne keller
et alain milon on savait déjà que ces
quatre sénateurs ump a le elle et se
prononcer pour l'ensemble de ce projet
de loi c'est donc normal s'ils ont bien
donné leur accord à cet article 1er mais
également le sénateur ump de moselle
françois grosdidier
il a voté pour cet article le premier
est déjà cet après midi ils avaient voté
à plusieurs reprises pour certains
amendements notamment ceux d'alain milon
peut-être qu'au final est bien cela fera
un cinquième sénateur ump vendredi qui
va apporter son soutien à ce projet de
loi du gouvernement héros alors une
autre information intéressante et bien
c'est que le sénateur ump des
hauts-de-seine et ancien ministre roger
karoutchi n'a pas pris part au vote il
ne s'est pas abstenu
une nappe carrément un pas pris part au
vote c'est une information également
intéressante chez les centristes sans
surprise également chantal jouanno a
voté pour
il y a également plusieurs abstentions
notamment celles de muguette dini les
sénatrice centriste du rhône l'a dit en
séance elle s'abstient sur cet article
mais elle votera en revanche l'ensemble
du projet de loi
et puis
dans le groupe rdse bien c'est jean
pierre chevènement et pierre yves
collombat les sénateurs rdse qui n'ont
pas pris part au vote
un vote contre celui de gilbert barbier
et les deux sénateurs corse nicolas
alfonsi et françois vendasi n'ont pas
pris part au vote
voilà quelques indications déjà ep voilà
quelques indications déjà sur ce qui
pourrait bien augurer du vote final des
sénateurs ici alors on retourne tout de
suite dans l'hémicycle pour suivre la
suite des débats l'amendement 17
rectifié bisky un avis favorable de la
commission et un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui est pour vous
une très belle unanimité l'amendement 17
rectifié bis est adopté
pourquoi dessus il y en a je vais mettre
aux voix l'article 1er bis à j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe ump
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le foot et pour remettront un bulletin
blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre un
bulletin robe bleue ce qui soit
s'abstenir un bulletin rouge
jean pierre michel le rapporteur du
projet de loi est sorti quelques
instants de l'hémicycle pour venir sur
notre antenne déjà votre première
réaction à l'adoption de l'article
premier du projet loi avec une majorité
assez confortable d'une majorité
confortable d'une dizaine de voix si je
comptais donc c'est une bonne majorité
qui se retrouvera je pense à la fin du
texte
parti premier c'est l'article est
essentielle parce que c'est celui qui
ouvre le mariage aux personnes de même
sexe cette antique et adoptez donc donc
après le résultat ce n'est pas est
important mais là tu es premier le plus
important il a été voté tout à l'heure
après beaucoup de discussions beaucoup
de prises de 9 heures et demie de débat
ici au sénat mon point de vue c'est que
jusque là je trouve assez normal
finalement que l'opposition s'exprime
même si elle l'a fait de façon
répétitive
parce que ces articles premier c'est la
principale du texte il est opposé donc
elle le dit voilà et elle fait un peu
durer les choses
maintenant je pense que l'opposition
devrait comprendre qu'elle devrait
permettre que le débat se déroule dans
des conditions normales c'est à dire
sans multiplier les prises de parole les
explications de vote et c'est ce que
parce que j'allais dire le plus gros est
fait l'important a été fait elle s'est
exprimée avec entendu enfin oui et que
maintenant elles devraient sinon parce
que j'ai eu quand même des tweets etc où
tout le monde ne trouve pas tellement
très bien cette son retard dans les
travaux parlementaires
alors autant je dis que jusqu'à
maintenant je peux comprendre autant à
partir de maintenant je pense qu'il faut
aller un peu accéléré quoi il y avait
quand même une volonté de débats assez
importante même si je pense que les
discussions autour les amendements des
articles sur l'adoption plénière là
aussi il va y avoir beaucoup de débats à
voir mais justement lance moment on
discute d'articles qui sont vraiment
secondaires on peut le dire et on a
encore discuté publiquement n'est pas
l'opposition qui est minorité avec une
opposition solide retard en séance ça
paraît normal ce qui était anormal c'est
que la majorité soit minoritaire était
le gars qui était le cas c'est le cas
elle était with demande d'un public à
répétition tout l'après midi
il faut dire qu'en même temps comme une
séance et des quatre commissions qui se
réunissait ce qui est absolument anormal
aussi je crois pas qu'un café en ville
de perles en commission il y avait
beaucoup de parlementaires
sénateurs qui étaient en temps de
monsieur lefort la devise des affaires
étrangères et c'est donc donc vous
appeler maintenant les parlementaires de
gauche à se mobiliser dans les matières
de gauche sont dans les mythiques je
crois l'opposition aussi bête en moins
grand nombre parce que normal très bien
merci beaucoup jean pierre michel je
vous laisse recourir dans les musiques
voilà y repart en cours aujourd'hui
michel leur rapporteur socialiste de ce
projet de loi ici au sénat qui avait
chanté à michel qui avait également
travaillé à l'époque sur le pacs voilà
on va retourner en séance avec paris
dakar il a pris la route de séance
gilles poursuit le déroulé des
amendements et des articles en
l'écoutant
j'en arrive à l'article 1er bis b j'ai
une demande de de parole excusez moi
monsieur bas monsieur rebsamen
oui je j'en ai pas pour très longtemps
je voudrais pas rallonger les débats
mais je voudrais souligner la forte
mobilisation de l'ensemble des sénateurs
et sénatrices de la gauche rassemblée ce
soir
puisque qu'est ce que nous avons eues
mais vous êtes bons joueurs et je n'en
doutais pas puisque nous avons eu tout à
l'heure à procès le mot est bien fort
quelques remarques un peu acerbe sur
l'utilisation de du scrutin public en
permanence
puis je mes chers collègues que vous
renvoyer cet argument est ce compliment
en vous demandant comme vous l'avez fait
pour l'auteur de ne pas en abuser
la nuit est longue nous pourrions
avancer ensemble beaucoup plus vite et
dès qu'il y a des points de convergence
nous venons de le voir avec l'amendement
de notre collègue gélard nous pouvons le
faire mais je voulais en profiter pour
dire combien à l'occasion du vote de ce
texte
nos collègues qui cet après midi étaient
réunies et travailler en commission son
sang présent sans présents et ils
peuvent en témoigner que ce soit le
président raúl que ce soit le plan
marque soit le président carrère les uns
les autres ont mobilisé dans leurs
commissions pour faire des auditions et
donc c'est avec une certaine fierté que
je salue l'ensemble des collègues de la
gauche ce soir a semblé merci
merci merci monsieur rebsamen la parole
est à philippe ans sur l'article 1er bis
b je vous remercie madame la présidente
mes chers collègues en toute autre
circonstance ces dispositions qui ont
été introduites par l'assemblée
nationale avant d'être modifiée par
notre commission des lois m'aurait paru
apporter des souplesse supplémentaire
qui correspondront qui correspondent
bien à vrai dire à la tente d'un certain
nombre de financer et de leurs familles
il s'agit en effet de permettre que le
mariage se déroule le non seulement dans
la commune où habite l'un ou l'autre des
futurs époux mais aussi dans la commune
de leurs parents je suis néanmoins
préoccupé du fait que cette disposition
est introduite à l'intérieur d'un texte
qui ouvre le mariage aux personnes de
même sexe et je m'explique
parce que je conçois que ce que je suis
en train de vous dire peut surprendre
certains d'entre vous mais nous avons
maintenant une notion de parents qui est
déjà très large et qui va être encore
élargies par ce texte
encore que je suppose qu'il s'agisse
d'une parenté au sens restreint du terme
et non pas d'une parentèle au sens large
sans quoi il suffirait de dire que le
mariage peut être célébrée dans
n'importe quelle commune de france mais
prenons le cas où il c'est une parenté
au sens étroit du terme
nous avons le domicile du fus premier
futur époux le domicile du deuxième
futurs époux mais comme nous avons eu
l'occasion de le répéter au cours de ce
débat s'agissant des parents il y a
potentiellement 4 par an avec quatre
domiciles distincts
aujourd'hui
nous sommes déjà à 6 domicile et si vous
regardez de plus près encore ce texte
vous constatez que la condition pour
pouvoir célébrer le mariage dans une
commune est remplie dès lors qu'il ya
une habitation continue de moi un mois
l'un des quatre parents des futurs époux
peut-être en villégiature loin de chez
lui
courchevel carnac je pourrais citer
d'autres communes bien sûr mais je ne
cite que celle ci pour l'exemple il y en
a gérard longuet le disait mais tout le
monde n'a pas pu l'entendre 30 36 mille
autres - 2 mais je m'en tiens à cette
énumération
je veux dire par là qu'en réalité nous
ouvrons la voie à la célébration du
mariage pratiquement dans n'importe
quelle commune de france alors je vois
bien l'intention qui est derrière ceci
qui est tout de même de permettre un
petit peu de souplesse là où nous en
manquons mais si vous ajoutez les
résidences secondaires où il est très
facile de prouver la domiciliation
pendant au moins un mois
ça fait quand même beaucoup de communes
or ces dispositions et je suis venu avec
le code civil qui bien sûr est notre
bible à tous s'inscrit dans le chapitre
iii du code civil sur les actes de
mariage et que dit pour l'essentiel ce
chapitre et et bien ce chapitre dit
qu'il faut et je résume publier les bans
mais pourquoi faut-il publier les bans
et où les publics dont les bancs sont
publiés dans la commune où le mariage
doit être célébré chacun d'entre nous
surtout ceux d'entre nous qui sont
maires le savent bien et pourquoi publie
ton les bancs et bien tout simplement
nous publions les bancs depuis des temps
immémoriaux
parce qu'il y à des interdictions au
mariage d opposition au mariage
et si le mariage est célébré dans
n'importe qui
communes de france la famille ne sera
pas connue et qui pourra à ce moment-là
s'opposer au mariage en disant qu'il ya
un soupçon de consanguinité par exemple
entre les époux or la question est
devenue plus compliquée du fait de
l'élargissement du mariage aux couples
de même sexe du développement de
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
en france et par conséquent je tiens à
vous dire que sous des dehors anodin
cette disposition en réalité ouvre la
voie à des conséquences absolument
incontrôlable et compris à la
possibilité que des mariages qui
normalement devraient être interdits ne
reçoivent aucune opposition car ils ont
été célébrées en catimini loin du pays
où la famille est connue
voilà donc pour cette intervention de
philippe bas le sénateur ump autour du
rôle futur des maires dans le cadre des
cérémonies de mariage homosexuel avant
le mariage pour tous se voient la fiba
qui avait le gros code civil sous le
bras on va rejoindre une dernière fois
delphine girard en tribune de presse
pour faire un point général sur cette
séance aujourd'hui ce soir s'annonce
très très longue
oui effectivement très très longue on
l'a dit plus de neuf heures et demie de
débats avant de voter cet article 1er
tout l'après-midi et bien l'ump est
délibérément entré dans une stratégie
d'obstruction parlementaire en
multipliant les prises de parole et les
explications de vote est la même à
nouveau demandé et bien
le coup là là là le quorum à savoir si
il y avait suffisamment de sénateurs en
séance pour voter et bien même la
majorité absolue des sénateurs n'étaient
pas réunies il a donc fallu aux
suspendre la séance eux pendant deux
heures avant de voter cet article 1er la
tension est retombée d'un cran après le
vote et on a le sentiment est bien que
les sénateurs qui vont siéger cette nuit
ont envie d'aller un petit peu plus vite
et de rationaliser les débats en tous
les cas et bien on pourra suivre la
suite de ces débats sur notre antenne à
partir de demain matin voilà péri ce que
l'on pouvait dire ce soir
oui rendez-vous effectivement demain
matin à partir de 10h30 pour revoir la
séance de cette nuit sur notre antenne
9h30 donc de débats aujourd'hui pour
aboutir finalement au vote de l'article
premier de ce projet de loi article qui
ouvre donc le mariage aux couples
homosexuels
je vous propose de réécouter le résultat
du vote annoncé par jean pierre bel le
président du sénat c'était il ya environ
une demi heure dans l'hémicycle ici
annonce les résultats du scrutin numéro
148 sur l'article premier du projet de
loi
nombre de votants 342 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
336 majorité absolue 169 pour l'adoption
179 contre 157 le sénat a adopté
l'article premier du projet de loi
voilà donc pour cette première étape
importante franchie dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi mariage pour
tous ici au sénat c'était il ya une
demi-heure donc le vote de l'article 1er
sur le texte merci de nous avoir suivi
en direct tout au long de la journée sur
notre antenne pour revoir la séance de
nuit qui va se dérouler à partir de
maintenant et bien rendez vous demain
matin à partir de 10h30 sur public sénat
est très bonne soirée à tous sur notre
antenne